foreign
I grew up
in this financial world in the academic
side and in the professional financial
side
and the problem with us Financial groups
nerds
is that we thought I thought and most of
them think that you solve your money
problems
with math
yeah math is part of it we always say
around here personal finances eighty
percent Behavior it's 20 head knowledge
the mathematics of becoming a
multi-millionaire you learn by the sixth
grade right there is no calculus
involved no trigonometry involved the
Pythagorean theorem is not involved
thank God okay there's no geometry
involved there is um it is it is
multiplication addition division that's
it you know some subtraction but yeah I
mean that's the mathematics of wealth
building so it really isn't math
if we were doing math he wouldn't ever
go take out a credit card and run up 18
or 20 debt because that's just freaking
mathematical Insanity that's right no no
sane human would do that and say I did
that for mathematical reasons that's
complete BS so this is not a math
problem it's a behavior problem
and that was really hard for me in the
early days of doing what I do today 30
years ago because I'm always trying I'm
a math guy I'm always trying to fix it
with the math right but it's not a math
problem and the part that goes with that
is even harder
is you're not by yourself
you got all these other dadgum humans
in the equation that's called
relationships that you actually have to
talk into doing crap yeah that's smart
that's your kids your grown kids your
grandkids and most of all your spouse
as we studied over ten thousand
millionaires over 85 percent of them
said their spouse was a contributing
factor the unity in their relationship
was a contributing factor in their
ability to build wealth meaning that
over 85 percent of millionaires work
together with their spouse are unified
in their approach to life and money
that's right
so if you think you're going to drag
some princess into wealth
or princess you think you're going to
drag some guy who won't work or doesn't
want to participate I'll I'll work hard
I'm gonna get me a truck no you're just
a redneck
that's all you are I know you I am you I
get it I got a truck in the parking lot
with loud dead gun Mufflers I get I know
who you are okay I get who you are but
that but you don't work hard enough to
be stupid I work hard I deserve you
don't deserve spit shut up
you know you gotta learn to work
together with your spouse and we hear
this over and over and over again and I
don't know if we spend enough time on
this show talking about it's freaking
vital but you're on the same page yep
is vital accountability that's part part
of the reason one of the one of the
benefits of marriage is accountability
and holding each other accountable make
each other better and if you're not
willing to uh get on the same page with
one of your most important
um parts of your marriage which is your
finances this is an opportunity for you
to exercise that muscle but a lot of
people won't do it because it takes work
it'll change your marriage in a positive
way when you learn how to handle money
because where you spend your money Jesus
said your Courageous where your heart is
where you spend your money says what's
important to you that's right Thank God
It's Friday I'm gonna hit the bars we
know what's important to you you know
I'm going to save for the future we know
what's important to you I'm gonna say
for my kids and we know it's important
I'm going to save so much I'm gonna
change my family tree my kids and my
great can grandkids now we know what's
important to you I want a car now we
know what's important to you I want some
shoes what's those shoes Rachel's got
with the red bottom oh Christian
Louboutin oh those are Jimmy Jimmy Choo
yeah those dad gum shoes are expensive
you better you better be freaking Rachel
Cruz if you're gonna she can wear them
she can get as many as she wants if
you're gonna buy those shoes by God you
need to have some coin I know that's
right all right and that's just you know
that's a deal but if you are a woman and
you come home with those shoes and
you're making 60 000 a month or a year
and your kids college funded and funded
hello I must threw the pin I must threw
the pin don't throw the pin oh I won't
throw it at you Jade throws the pen it's
over that is a glaring indicator that
you become what's known as an
irresponsible
human being you cleaned that up I did
I've had to clean it up a couple of
times Dave
that was fun I can't say everything I
want to say but you know you know what
I'm saying you know irresponsible human
being yeah
yeah
seriously if you can't and I I gotta
tell you I've been married 41 years
Sharon I just got back from an
anniversary trip we were living like no
one else we've been gone for three weeks
all right and um
you know what we did on that trip
anything we wanted you know why because
most of our Lives we didn't do
everything we wanted if you live like no
one else later you can live and give
like no one else you've had to pay a
freaking price to win no one wins
accidentally and part of the price is
sometimes my wife is right
I don't like that but it's also true who
can find a virtuous wife for her worth
is far above rubies the heart of her
husband safely trusts her get this part
he will have no lack of gain
when I'm in when I'm when my wife who's
a full-time mom for 40 38 years
uh has an opinion about something maybe
Dave Ramsey needs to listen to that
because maybe if I don't it's going to
cost me in excess of 10 grand every time
I go against one of her feelings that
doesn't mean she's always right but it
means I need to respect that and we've
got to be if we're not in agreement on
major purchases or major giving and our
giving sometimes is more difficult these
days to decide on than purchases yeah
because if we're going to give a chunk
to something and really help some
movement or thumb some thing over here
and we're not in agreement we don't both
have a good feeling about the group that
we're dealing with that Ministry that
we're dealing with then we don't go
forward and that's good you know that's
so good Dave because when you're not on
the same page or when the guy just
thinks I'm going to do what I want or
the the woman thinks I'm going to do
what I want there's a lack of respect
there at the core and that's why some
sometimes when we get calls and it's
like you know I'm trying to do this
thing but you know my spouse is doing
another thing I'm always like this is
not a money problem at the core this is
you he doesn't respect you or you don't
respect him and that is a bigger problem
because at the end of the day you need
to be able to have these conversations
and feel like
that person's listening to you feel like
they're respecting what you're saying
feel like they care enough about what
you're saying to enact some sort of
change whether it's something that
you're compromising on or them fully
coming over to your side or vice versa
but when that's not there y'all got
y'all got troubles and it's not money
trouble that's right and it's gonna it's
gonna come up again and again and again
and you're going to struggle with your
money that's right because opposites do
attract that nerd will attract that free
spirit that person who loves to save
will attract that person who loves to
spend I'm a spender Sharon's a natural
saver I'm a nerd I like to do the
budgets the projects she couldn't care
less about the details yeah this trip we
were on I've got to have everything
ironed out I got to know exactly where
we're going to win I don't making it up
as you go is not relaxing for Dave
you got the itinerary but she completely
she's per yeah but she she knew the
itinerary but she would just be asking
me what are we doing next because she
doesn't want to do that so Opposites
Attract Larry Burkett used to say it's a
good thing because if two people just
alike get married one of you is
unnecessary so you need each other you
need the strengths of the other one and
you need to be unified off of those
strengths but if you're making all your
decisions with half your brain because
one of you is not voting or one of his
vote doesn't count in the relationship
then you are not going to win
relationally and you're not going to win
with your money it is there's not an
exception this is a universal rule I'm
independent good don't get married
you're gonna be a useless spouse that is
so true I mean dependent or kiss my no
way yeah no way please don't screw up
somebody else's life with your
Independence when you get married you're
by God dependent for richer for poorer
in sickness and in health Choose Wisely
who's making the chicken soup when you
got the flu Miss Independent Mr
independent
your butt be up in the bed looking for
some food that's what's happening come
on that's not independent that's
dependent